but it's a question of do you want your
country to be owned by
people who pay tax or not
and if you do then it doesn't matter
where they go because
it's it's your country and you can ask
the people who are in your country to
pay tax on those assets so um
i think it's it's very very simple
really and i think it all comes down to
this you know roman abramovich was not
able to put chelsea football club in a
bag you know and these rich people no
matter where they go
this country will still exist and the
assets will still exist and they can be
taxed here and um
i think when you understand it like that
you realize it's actually very simple of
course we can tax them and that raises
the question well why don't we then and
um you know there are a lot of possible
reasons why that could be but i'm going
to give you a couple suggested reasons
number one rishi sonic is the 222nd
richest man in the country he's worth
over 700 million pounds his
father-in-law is one of the richest men
in the entire world and he chooses the
tax laws